the northern realms are a dangerous
place but with New Game+ coming to the
witcher 3 there couldn't be a better
time to hone those witcher skills and
take a stab at the game's hardest
difficulty death march if you do plan on
undertaking this challenge here are some
tips and tricks every witcher should
live by
now this may seem like a basic one but
it's something that even the more
seasoned witchers shouldn't overlook
especially during the first ten or so
hours of the game just because you could
scrape through a fight on the normal
difficulty with low health it doesn't
mean you can on death march sometimes
you have to embrace that flight
mentality and run for the hills if your
health is low or if you are thin on
resources sometimes the best idea is
usually to hop on your trusty steed
Roach and ride on out of there in most
cases whoever or whatever you're hunting
will be waiting for you when you are
better equipped Geralt has two evasive
moves he can roll or he can dodge
rolling creates more distance between
Geralt and his foe but it also drains
stamina now dodging on the other hand
let's go outside step away from attacks
without sucking up any of his precious
stamina unless you intend to run it is
in your best interest to learn how to
dodge effectively not only does dodging
spare your stamina but it also keeps
Geralt within arm's reach of his foes
making it much easier to get in a few
strikes before the enemy can reposition
themselves right from the get-go you
should start sinking your ability points
Indic when it is hands-down the most
useful spell on harder difficulties
because it essentially lets you take an
extra hit or two depending on how you've
leveled it up no matter what kind of
build you are going for I'd recommend
leveling up the active shield ability
this will allow you to recover health
when you are hit before you approach a
group of enemies cask when as long as
you see a gold spark circling girl it
means his shield is ready to deflect any
kind of blow thrown at him after you've
been hit back off and wait for your
stamina to recharge once it's up cast
the spell again and take up an offensive
position death march is designed to
force you to prepare for fights if you
are walking into a big fight or if
you're at the tail end of a monster
contract don't neglect your friendly
merchants scattered throughout the land
make sure you are stocked up on food
water and of course those tasty chicken
sandwiches research which you are
hunting make sure your potions are
filled to the brim and prepare oils for
your blades right when you start your
adventure on death march brewing the
swallow potion should be one of your
four
priorities as it is an easy way to
monitor gerelds health at the beginning
of new game+ the players also given a
potion that allows Geralt to respect his
abilities if you do respect I'd
recommend doubling down on the fast
attack skills arrow deflection brewing
and of course when there are thousands
of combinations from there but those
will cover your bases there you have it
those are 4 tips every Witcher should
add to their coat of arms if they're
brave enough to take on some of the
game's harder difficulties feel free to
leave your tips in the comments below
and for more on the Witcher 3 stay tuned
to game spot
you